zulte alors ya aussi le football le
champion du monde lilian thuram comme
vous originaire de la guadeloupe est un
an après l'exploit sollicité dans tous
les stades de l'hexagone ce week-end le
département de seine-et-marne avait même
organisé un challenge thuram au stade de
melun à l'endroit même où le footballeur
avait chaussé ses premiers crampons un
retour émouvant pour le footballeur qui
parrainait samedi dernier pour la plus
grande joie des joueurs en herbe le
tournoi des jeunes équipes de la région
samantha ramsamy gueule leblanc était au
rendez vous le challenge lilian thuram
une fête un tournoi et surtout la
présence du champion du monde
ambiance joyeuse autour de la coupe du
monde que le héros ambassadeurs du jour
brandis sur la fameuse chanson tout le
monde se souvient que le 12 juin dernier
la grande fête du mondial débuté au
stade de melun personne n'a oublié et
répond-t-il dans les tribunes est lilian
thuram très synchrone
aujourd'hui il ya du niveau ça ressemble
à ça rassemble bien de toutes les
équipes de cinéma via lilian thuram on
peut les approcher
j'ai un autographe je suis content ma
mère va être contente
voici on peut on à la coupe du monde
royal
il ya plein de raisons encore on peux
pas les citer comme ça quand je vois la
ceinture comme ça avec malin il dit ils
disent jouer au foot mais travailler à
l'école le message ce serait comme je
les dis c'est le respect qu sonné mais
le respect des autres est ce que comme
ça peut-être on améliorait peut-être la
vie en société
visiblement lilian thuram aime les
enfants et le lui rendent bien